so it's higher titers increased
viability more protein being produced
per cell it's very versatile versatile
it can work with mammalian cells like
chinese hamster ovary cells HEK cells
very common cell lines that we use in
the lab we can also use these bags to
grow insect cells and do baculovirus
expression which is another awesome
technology that we use in the lab again
we use each of these different systems
depending on the kind of protein that
we're trying to make and how that
protein is then made is it made in a
soluble form is it insoluble is the
protein secreted from the cell is the
protein does it reside inside the cell
is the protein a cell surface protein in
which case it's found on the surface of
the cell so depending on the kind of
protein we're trying to express that
really determines the method and how we
will grow or optimize the protein
expression you know we all build upon
each other's research and so and as I
said we all work in teams so I get to
work with course the project team the
therapeutic area project team the gene
expression people that do all the DNA
cloning the expression optimization
specialists like myself that then take
these cell lines and scale them up to
let's say a hundred liters I have to
make sure that we make the target
protein and that's done through
different technologies such as
polyacrylamide gels that we get to stain
we can stain for the proteins with a
kumasi based stain sometimes we have to
use like what's referred to as a Western
blot and use an illogical method to see
the protein so our job is to make sure
we're making the target protein of
interest and then that will then go to
the purification chemists who will
actually purify and make the pure
protein
that pure protein thing gets passed into
the therapeutic area well they will do
this assay development it may go to the
structural chemistry group where they
will try and crystallize and get the
crystal structure of the protein it may
go to the therapeutic area where they're
going to do high-throughput screening
and screen a hundred thousand pfizer
compounds a day against the target
protein so all of our work is really
based upon the person before us and
that's how we work together in teams to
make a drug